hello folks
welcome to rational science the only
site that does
physics right everybody else does
math and irrational explanations
something that you cannot even visualize
okay
we have a great day today lots of
questions if
i don't get to answer your questions
today
please ask it again because uh i was
over
overflown uh
okay so we're gonna divide the lecture
today in three parts
first part we're gonna do a little bit
of extinction very popular subject as i
found out over
the last few weeks and then i'm going to
do a little
bit of physics we have ray reverse
ray reversibility today okay now at the
end i'm gonna
try to answer questions comments that
people
made since last time okay let's get on
with it let's do the extinction part
first
fellow says uh you're using evidence
proof
etc is anthropology a non-science
well um evidence is not a part of
science
okay evidence uh is equal to proof
belief
it's what a what a prosecutor uses
to persuade convince
convert recruit to the jury that's the
purpose of
evidence now that doesn't stop
you from going out there and using
evidence for example in paleontology
where you find a certain bone in a
certain layer
of the rock you know fossil
and you say well this was approximately
60 000
years ago and you're going to use that
as a foundation
for an assumption okay
for a theory but you're going to use it
as an assumption in other words
you're going to say i'm going to assume
that this bone
belongs to so and so and it was
approximately 60
000 years ago that's the way you got to
look at it
it's not that you believe in it it's
that it forms the
hypothesis that you're going to use on
on which you're going to
base your theory okay so no it's not a
question of belief
it's a question of it becoming part of
the assumptions
okay uh on with the subject uh
specifically here we have something
about the neanderthals
and the uh denisovans uh some
fossils that were found in a russian
cave
uh very close to the border with
mongolia
okay and so uh phil says now that those
were closed
then he corrects himself he says my bad
i was thinking about the sewing
needles of the denisovans from 50
000 years ago technically uh
not neanderthals uh yeah i guess they
had uh
you know all these
catwalks in those days men uh trying
different clothes
and yeah probably you're right as well
maybe the um
uh the designers were all gay you know
just like in today
uh days of today you know uh
no i don't think i don't think they wore
clothes at all
none of them uh the first uh animals
to use clothes were humans and i think
no other animal
ever invented clothes and had any need
for it everyone was in his own world
in his own environment and that was
sufficient for them
they got used to it after thousands of
years of acclimatization
there was no need for any animal to use
clothes
except humans that suddenly went up
north
into europe and they found out it was
kind of cold out there
and i think they went up north because
they were probably following some kind
of herd looking for food
those days it was an issue of food
almost exclusively
okay so these um
humans which are going to become the
cro-magnons cro-magnon
uh in europe um
you know they they were subsistence
hunter gatherers all they did was hunt
and
and uh fish maybe you know maybe they
did some gathering
most of it was hunting that's why they
had those spears okay
spears were not used to hunt uh lettuce
or tomato okay
uh anyways this fall is referring to
this when he's talking about a needle
and i talked about that a little bit in
the past here's the needle they found
and you can see that small hole in the
needle
okay and it says the needle is seen
providing proof that the long gone
denisovans named
after the cave were more sophisticated
than previously believed
okay i don't think uh denisovans made
this
okay and let me tell you why look at on
the side it says the bracelet they found
a bracelet showed the denisovans to be
more technologically advanced
than homo sapiens or neanderthals no
problem there i have no problem with
that statement if it were true
okay if it had any validity whatsoever
and i like the next sentence
scientists found that a hole had been
drilled in part of the bracelet with
such
precision that it could only have been
done with high rotation drills similar
to those used today
okay so these folks what are they saying
they're saying that the
denisovans okay that these uh
animals these uh hunter-gatherers of the
uh upper paleolithic that they made that
bracelet
that fine bracelet and they drilled
holes in it
what a high-speed high-speed drill
yeah sure something is wrong
okay something is definitely wrong and i
found i can't find the
reference again i'm gonna still look for
it but i found a paper
that states that they confused or they
mixed really they mixed uh one of the
layers
or maybe a couple of the layers in the
uh
in the denisoman cave uh like
the 11th level with uh some other level
with the third level something like that
there was a mixture and
that's important because if something
like that happened
even remotely okay uh they could be
confusing something that happened in the
neolithic
maybe anywhere from five to fifteen
thousand years ago
with what happened in the upper
paleolithic when you're talking about up
to 50
000 years ago so that's that's
some confusion there okay so very
important to
to get down to the bottom of that and
again they don't talk too much about
that bracelet
should be a tremendous find
i mean if that bracelet is 50 000 years
50 000 years old
then uh it should be a
a seminal paper it should be you know
groundbreaking
discovery and nobody talks about it they
just mention it in passing
and that makes me suspicious also why
wouldn't they harp on something so
important such an important find okay so
it makes you kind of wonder
how they play around with all this and
here's a pendant that they found
also along the same lines it's got that
little hole drilled in there
it says direct radio carbon dating of
upper paleolithic tooth
pendants and bone points yielded the
earliest evidence for the production of
these
artifacts in northern eurasia again
they're talking about
primarily russia okay between 43 and 49
000 years ago okay and i like that last
sentences
it says it is not currently possible to
determine whether
anatomically modern humans were involved
in their production uh yeah like
uh how anatomically modern humans like
you know
uh those working in um in
in moscow today maybe they maybe they
drill those hills
i mean i don't know i have a hard time
believing that
any animal 50 000 years ago made little
holes like that
for what for what purpose for
ornamentation
well that's what they say that they did
these things like hung them around
themselves or whatever
you know i have a hard time believing
that they made these things
a harder time believing they made
needles they had no need for needles so
there was no need to make them
okay and i'm wondering what they use as
thread
i mean if you're going to make a little
needle with a little hole they got to
get
some some kind of uh string
or thread to go through that hole
i think that's an even bigger jump you
know we didn't discover that until much
later
so i have a problem with all this stuff
then these people are trying to
sell you the notion that animals in the
past
use clothes okay and we're talking about
animals just like i'm saying
they won't take away from that they were
two-legged animals but they were animals
in the worst sense of the word okay
first needle as far as i'm concerned the
kostenki
needle dates to anywhere again wide
range here see the other one has a very
close range
it's farther back in time this one is
closer to us but it's got a wider range
anywhere between 20 and 36 000 years ago
that makes a lot more sense because if
humans
like i make the assumption of entered
europe
somewhere around anywhere between 35 and
40 000 years ago
this would fall right at the limit uh
where we could find needles
okay and that means that why because
they had to invent clothes they had to
sew these clothes
and someone came up with the idea of the
needle
i don't think they had any need for
clothes before then
i don't think they wore clothes until
they got into europe
and that's where when clothes were
invented neanderthals never knew
anything about clothes
neither did heidelberg because if
neanderthals needed clothes well what
happened to the nano
the high dopers who came a couple
hundred thousand years before them how
about the homo erectus
which was already in western europe
um somewhere around eight anywhere from
eight hundred thousand to one million
years ago
so if if like you get to the caves of
arapuerka
in spain and they found uh antecessor
and he they say 800 000 years ago how
did that fellow live
in the cold did he have needles also did
he
also used clothes i don't think so i
think these
animals these two-legged animals they
they went up there
these gorillas and eventually got used
to the cold
and they gave birth to heidelberg who
gave birth
birth to neanderthal and saw him down
the line
i don't think uh i don't think any of
these
wore clothes any more than a polar bear
wears clothes
so no no needles i think the first
needle came with humans
okay but let's get to this these
denisovans who are these
folks okay and here's the map okay
uh the denisovan cave is right there on
the southern
mid-southern part of russia close to
mongolia and kazakhstan
and then they found four bones
essentially there four sets of bones
uh three teeth three molars and one
pinky uh phalanx and then in uh
china a couple years ago they found a
mandible
and they say that's also a denissimon
so assuming they are all dennis events
well we're talking about a region
in you could say eastern or central
asia there where these tennis events
lived
okay very possible i have no problem
with that
uh where these the same thing same types
of animals as neanderthals whether
could they mate with humans i would say
no and no
i don't think they had anything to do
with either one and maybe they weren't
the only ones
the only types of humans or humanoids or
homos over there that um
that those are the ones we know about
maybe there were more
i mean again i look at the middle east
the levant israel uh
iraq syria they have caves
where they say they found neanderthals
but those neanderthals are different
than the neanderthals the classical
neanderthals
of germany france uh england and spain
they're different they notice
differences okay if there are
differences maybe this was another
species
that was out there in the middle east
maybe they had nothing to do with humans
uh so we got to look at all this um
where are these neanderthals
and uh and again you know i think we may
be missing
like they found florence's uh in uh
in the philippines uh relatively
recently and they said these little
uh men were living on an island uh
island dwarfism
affected them so they were small they
were uh like pygmies okay
and they were isolated from humanity
it's like a different species
and i'm sure something similar existed
in the upper paleolithic there was
probably a mosaic
of different types of humans in
different parts of the world
primarily i would say judging just by
the evidence that we have
if if i were to formulate a hypothesis
an assumption i would say well you know
right now at least i can divide them in
three groups we can say there's the
denisovans
at least in central asia i would say
south western asia middle east some
other
animal maybe
somewhere genealogically between humans
and
neanderthals out west western europe
neanderthals south africa we have
um humans
and i think that we had this mosaic
and i think if we were to find more
bones we would probably find that
there were quite a bit of differences
between all these
uh human-like creatures that lived
in those days so that's my take on that
based on the evidence that we have today
that's all you can formulate
or that at least that's what i formulate
as far as an assumption
okay uh this is what they found in
um in those two regions the one in
russia and the one in china
the first five that are on the upper
and uh to the
left okay um
that's your left yeah that's i think
it's your left
um those are all from the uh
the denisovan cave and then the one at
the bottom of the mandible that's what
they found a couple years ago
in the by shia karsta cave in china
okay and you can see i put the dates
there approximately when these
uh so-called individuals
you know for lack of a better word these
denisovans as they say
lived okay and there's quite a bit of
spread apparently
there were different um hominids uh
using the cave
at different points in time that's
possible i think they have like 22
levels
over there in that game they're looking
for stuff at different levels
see what they can find in each one and
that's what they found so far this is it
this is all we have from the dis events
there you have all
up to today 2021 okay this is all we
have
and the question is if um if
these are the same as the
neanderthals okay especially the ones
that are
said to be neanderthals for example
there you see number 11
and that's supposed to be a
mixture a half breed between a
neanderthal
and a denisova okay a girl
apparently 13 years old and they say uh
that's a little bone from they don't
really know where they think it's
maybe from a female or who knows where
but the point is they did a dna analysis
on these
and well this these are their
conclusions so far
but again they they look at
interbreeding because that's
that's so popular among geneticists who
have taken
over the neanderthal extinction business
okay okay
so uh here we have the altai neanderthal
okay and the altai nando's though is
that
denis of a5 um and that bone there that
orange bone on the upper
left that you see there um 120
000 years ago they say that that
neanderthal
that neanderthal does not really match
the neanderthals
in the west there are differences
many different genetic differences okay
and here i put in a sample of one of the
western
neanderthals okay just for reference
but the point is that bone there would
not fit
the guy in the lower right that's that's
my argument okay so these bones they say
they're neanderthals
because they're closely related to the
neanderthals in other words
there are similarities like their
similarities between us and the
neanderthals
does that mean we had sex with them no
does that mean that these guys had sex
with the neanderthals no maybe it's
another creature out there for all we
know a different
species okay but they say they call them
neanderthals
and so they talk about the altai
neanderthal
and so they say oh the neanderthals went
all the way to the east
and uh probably beyond uh the um
denisovan cave right now we're we're
stuck at the denisovan cave
but tomorrow they find one in china
maybe in peking or beijing
or shanghai or wherever you know and
they're going to stretch the
neanderthal empire all the way to china
you know i don't think that ever
happened i i think the neanderthals did
not go that far
east if if i were to guess they stopped
somewhere around the between the caspian
and the
black sea somewhere there and up north
of
a certain line i don't think they even
went south like to iran
and saudi arabia or the middle east
i don't think neanderthals went that far
south they had no need to go down there
they had enough food
up north they were born in the cold
and polar bears don't usually migrate to
the equator
and i think that's why netherlands would
have never gone that far south okay
that's my take on that
let me get this one out of here
okay um let me show you some teeth
comparisons
so that you can see why i also have
doubts that the denisovans
had anything at all to do with either
humans or
neanderthals okay i think they were i
mean they were they
they were totally different species of
some kind of
two-legged uh hominid of some kind
but uh they were so different that they
would not have been able to mate with
either
neanderthals or humans okay and
here's you can see it from the teeth
here's the knees about four
and eight and they have monster tees
compared to both neanderthals and humans
their their mullers were very big
and you say well what kind of creature
had these teeth
because here you're talking about a
creature that
those teeth they belong to a different
age you're talking about
even before the days of
heidelberg by that i don't mean that the
denisovans dated from that
time what i'm saying they had a level of
development
very closely related to something
between a heidelberg
and homo erectus so their teeth
really matched something along the lines
of
i don't know i would say maybe homo
erectus some
some creature that lived in those days
and i'll give you an example here okay
here's an example
here's a mouth of a chimp and then you
have
a ultra astrology epithecus
uh afarensis and a human you can see
that their teeth are different
okay and the size is important to look
at here
and i'm saying that these denisovans had
teeth more closely related to afarensis
than they had to humans or even to
neanderthals which approached uh the
the mouth said or the teeth the set of
teeth that humans had
these guys were more like afarensis and
you may say well what did aferensis
looks like it looked like i mean uh
was he um uh was he anything
similar any where similar to us well
here it is this is what
uh afarensis looks like so if these guys
have big molars
like afarensis well maybe
i would say that maybe you're talking
about two-legged monkey of some kind
some gorilla that was out there that was
a denisovan
to say that denis evans looked more or
less like
neanderthals or humans i don't know i
have great doubts about that
and that they would have sex in the wild
when everybody fears everybody else and
everybody attacks
everybody else in the wild without 911
there to protect anyone
no laws it's just the law of the
strongest
and so yeah i would say that there would
not have been
uh a powwow where they all mean they
trade squaws and they all have sex with
them
you know i i have grave dogs this is
what they need to explain
see these folks uh they jump to
conclusions
because of genetic uh evidence again
and they say oh uh there's so much uh
commonality between this animal and this
animal they had sex
well you know we have commonality with
chimps with uh
orangutans with even with gorillas
if you look at our dna we have some
commonality
does that mean we have we had sex with
them can we have sex with
a champ well you know they they try to
make that human z
a human in a chimpanzee a mixture in the
1920s russian guy
and he failed you can't you can't put a
chimp together with a human and come up
with a third
type of species it doesn't work that way
nothing comes out
and so again to say that
humans mated with neanderthals is more
or less the same thing
we were separated by hundreds of
thousands of years
uh uh separation but it's not so much
the time i think there's something more
important which is
the environment the nfls grew in in cold
arctic weather
they probably still had their their i i
imagined them as the woolly man they
probably had hairs
like the uh willy mammoth or the
woolly rhinoceros they probably had
hairs all over
part of their protection against the
cold
maybe they acquired it maybe they never
lost it because maybe homo erectus
already was a
woolly kind of guy and he went out there
and it was cold and it helped protect
them and it just developed even further
until neanderthals were completely
immune to the cold
they never knew what cold was they had
no reason to invent clothes
certainly not from 200 300 000 years ago
which is when they
are assumed to have been born in europe
so from day one they started building
clothes oh it's so cold out there
no and did they have fire yeah they
probably had fire i think they did
i make that assumption and did they use
it for
warmth i think they used it primarily to
cook their food if
that's maybe what they used it for and
more important than that for protection
they probably used it as a weapon
that's what they use fire for humans did
the same thing
okay we had fire did we need fire in
africa in in the equator
i don't think so not for not for warmth
we probably used it to defend ourselves
we
realized that animals were scared of
that we
came to that conclusion and said hey i
can use this as i can scare the lion
away with this
okay so i think it was used primarily as
a weapon
okay um
what's all this about i'm saying all
this is about
genetics and what i mean by that i mean
it's politics
150 politics what happened was in 1990
all the way to 2003 for 13 years they
developed this
human genome project okay a lot of money
went into that
okay and the bottom line was that
it was to create this genomic
uh revolution okay
and if you look at it the human genome
project there was a
study done out there uh what benefits we
got out of that
and today they've got this number where
they say that in fact obama mentioned in
one of his speeches there
saying that they got 140 for every one
dollar
invested okay in different branches
you know this ballooned this genome
project okay and says today
this industry is empowering further
scientific discovery progress and
commercial innovation
on a broad range of fronts from human
healthcare to veterinary medicine from
industrial biotechnology to high
productivity agriculture
and the main one which concerns us here
is the neanderthal extinction why am i
mentioning that well because it turns
out that for many years i would say at
least for
50 years if not more
they've been arguing the paleontologists
so-called paleontologists they've been
arguing about how the neanderthals
became extinct how did they go away
and uh the issue was that uh
we had essentially three currents one
was climate change
so popular today everybody talks about
climate change
uh the other one is that humans kill
them
we kill them off and another one is that
we out competed them
and they kind of imploded because of
that because
we muscled in on their territory they
could not compete with us
partly because the weather changed we
had protection they did not or we had
more resistance
maybe desistant resistance to bugs you
know
we out-competed them so those were the
three
uh groups big groups there were lit
smaller groups as well
but those were the three big ideas and
they were fighting amongst themselves
and then comes 1990 the genome project
what did they do well they went in there
and 2003 they finished the human genome
okay they got all these uh molecules in
the right place they had them all mapped
out they put them in computers so now we
can reference them
guess what 2007 2007
we had this gentleman svante pavo and he
was named by
times magazine as one of the 100 most
influential people of that year
and why did they do that because svanta
took
charge of the genome project at the max
planck institute in germany
and what they were going to do they they
were going to pull bones from
neanderthals and they're going to
they're going to do a genome
uh in other words they're going to look
at all the molecules that make up
the dna etc of a neanderthal
and so they could map that out and then
compare it against
the human genome project the
results that we have from there and in
three years
from 2007 to 2010 they finally finished
the project they published their
findings
and their findings were that there was
two percent approximately two percent
commonality between humans
and neanderthals and it was due to what
well they said at the time was
speculative
but speculation became law fact
proof and today we have that version
which is
no we did not kill the neanderthals we
did not out compete them it wasn't
climate change what was it
it was we loved them to death
we loved them to death what had happened
was that they say
we had sex with them massively
everywhere
in all their crawls we went in there had
sex with their women they had
sex with our females right we had great
parties
uh exchanged genes okay beer
as well okay and okay so once
they got together what happened how come
the neanderthals are not around today
well they said there's a smaller
population maybe a 10 to 1 ratio between
10 more 10 humans for every one
neanderthals
we were we outnumbered them so much that
their population kind of
uh diluted in ours and then from
that time onwards for the last next or
last
40 000 years uh we lost a lot of their
genes
and we ended up with the two percent we
have today that's the general story
okay the other version is that
our great grandfathers sometime maybe
anywhere from 500 to 800 000 years ago
they separated which was what homo
erectus one guy went
to europe the other guy went to or was
already
in africa this guy developed into
something called homo rhodesians which
was
similar to homo heidelbergensis in
europe
okay and from there came neanderthal in
europe and humans in africa
we migrated to europe and maybe we met
the neanderthals maybe they died and we
just
conquered their territory because there
was no one
to present opposition
those are the stories and so the
question is maybe
we have two percent because that's all
that's left after 800 000 years
in which the homo erectus
branched out one state in africa the
other went
to europe that's it that's why we have
two percent
okay so there's there should be no more
than that but they said no we had sex
why because first of all they had to
show that um they had to justify the two
percent
that's one issue but that's the least of
the issues the big issue was
we had to create jobs for geneticists
let me repeat that we had to create jobs
for geneticists
and uh there was this big fight in
neanderthal paleontology and they came
in there and they just took over
they wiped out all the paleontologists
say you guys are all ignorant you know
nothing
we're going to tell you how the
neanderthals disappeared
and we're going to do it through genetic
analysis so they went
in there okay and they did their uh
counting because of what is a geneticist
he's a mathematician nothing but he's a
lab boy
okay let me make that clear he only
knows how to count
molecules he does it through a computer
he doesn't have to use his head
he's got all these things out there
already mapped out
and from there they draw conclusions
and the conclusions they said oh we know
we had sex with them
okay i don't care about their data i
don't care about their dna
i don't care about any of that i'll
concede it i'll grant it
i want to know how it happened in the
wild
and you won't find a single paper this
is what i'm telling you
you won't find a single paper in
paleontology where it says how they did
it in the wild
how they came across each other how that
could have developed i mean you would
think at least they would come up with a
theory
there's nothing out there absolutely
nothing all they do
every time you look at a paper dealing
with the extinction of the neanderthals
it's dna dna dna genetics
dna that's all you'll find you won't
find anything else today
and that's a problem that's a serious
problem because it means
they've already ruled they already
decided that neanderthals
made it with us and they disappeared
because they dissolved in our bigger
population
period we're done never to be talked
about again
okay and so the paleontologist the guy
who studied paleontologists they go out
into the field they
pull a bone out and they say oh look
this bone is different than that one we
don't care
we don't get their different genetics
tells us they were they made it and
you're
that's it and so we got a problem
between the people traditional
paleontologists who said well you know i
looked at these bones and they looked so
different how could these
two uh hominids have had
sex if they're so different and the
other guy said we don't care about
anything we don't know anything about
bones
all we know is about dna and dna says we
have two percent
and we wouldn't have two percent if it
weren't that they had sex
we're done that's it that's all you'll
hear about from now on
and then they branched off into more and
more little things like oh the diseases
we inherited from neanderthals the ones
we gave to them
and they go through all this nonsense
about you know what color hair or eyes
they had
a bunch of nonsense we don't have a
theory for extinction that's what
paleontology is about that's what we
want to know about the neanderthals
and we don't have a uh a mechanism of
how this happened in the wild
how did the tiger and the lion meet in
the wild and have
you know uh what is that tygon or uh
what is it
uh i always get them wrong the thai gun
or the
lie whatever elias
okay how do you get these two animals to
mix in the wild
that's what we want to know okay does a
lion sleep with a leopard
does a lion sleep with a panther does a
lion sleep with a tiger
it may be in the zoo under control of
humans yeah
we can all believe that the question how
did they do that in the wild
especially apex predators see what they
always
give you as examples are herbivores
some animal out there say well here we
saw this and we think
because again it's all inference we
haven't seen it in the wild
but they infer because of dna that this
animal
came from these other two and i've
talked about that in the past where you
have the
red wolf which is supposedly a mixture
between
uh wolves and coyotes
and this animal came out they say
okay called the red wolf and again it
was all politics because what was the
issue the issue was that
there were some people who wanted to
protect the red wolf which is
in in almost becoming extinct they
wanted to protect it
it turns out the law does not protect
hybrids it only protects original
species
and so there was another group that said
oh we don't want to protect the red wolf
because it's not an original species
it's not a
authentic specie it's a half breed and
we can always
come up with a half breed by breeding a
wolf
with a coyote it turns out that they
never put a
wolf in a coyote in the same cage poor
coyote
in fact you'll see there's there's a
couple youtube video shows how
wolves treat coyotes they term the
pieces with their mouths
that's the amount of sex that's how much
love they have for them
so no i don't think a wolf ever raped a
coyote in the wild
but this is what they say is the red
wolf a mixture of
woes and coyotes and since there's more
than one
and there were more in the past we have
to assume lots of wolves had
sex with lots of coyotes when the wolf
is a
an animal that works as a pack whereas a
coyote is a lonely animal against like
the tiger which is a lonely
cat whereas the lion is a social cat
and there are too many differences for
them even if you put them in the same
regional same geographic region of the
planet
it would never happen they'd be fighting
they'd be killing each other
and that's what happens with the wolves
and coyotes so again they wanted to
protect one group wanted to protect the
red wolf because they say oh it's it's
original species and the
other one said no it's a half breed so
we're not going to protect it because
the law doesn't protect
and so it's all politics it's got to do
with one side
asking for money and pulling in his
direction compared to the other
group and if we can't tell about the red
wolf today which is still alive
how can you tell about neanderthal and
uh uh then this events
we're talking about 50 thousand years
ago
we're not even you know we don't even
have it in front of us to
be able to carry out an experiment or
anything like that it's all deduction
and all the deduction is from genetics
why because these people had to have a
job
and what the geneticists have done these
mathematicians who count
atoms and molecules what they've done
they've taken over
the paleontology neanderthal
paleontology business
that's what happened a lot of
paleontologists are not too happy about
that
anyways uh here's uh one article and
this was uh
from uh what is it nbc news says we're
neanderthals a separate species
scientists say yes
by a nose okay and it says one team of
specialists says neanderthals
nasal anatomy proves they were a species
of their own
their their whole uh nose thingy uh
respiratory tracts etc were totally
different than humans
okay by looking at a complete
morphological pattern
we can conclude that neanderthals are
our close relatives
but they are not us okay
okay so uh that's one opinion
one group that says no these guys were
not us
here's another one uh says what are the
differences okay
says the physical traits of homo sapiens
include a high
and rounded globular brain case and
relatively narrow
pelvis okay so our pelvis our brain case
totally different you can see there's
some comparison
uh does that guy on the left look like
the guy on the right do you need to be a
paleontologist to be able to tell me
those two guys are different
you really need to go to school to tell
me that
i mean you should be able to take a look
and find out one thing there's no
chin on the neanderthal he doesn't have
this
indentation no other hominin has the
indentation except
humans okay and we have the indentation
there
and neanderthal does not uh heavy
eyebrows
okay ours are kind of
you know whittled out they're shaved
the brain case very different okay
they have uh more like a gorilla uh
brain case okay
and you know there were other
differences among them that are saying
again the
nasal passages totally different okay it
says measurement of our brains in pelvic
shape
can reliably separate a modern human
from a neanderthal
their fossils exhibit a longer lower
skull and a wider pelvis
even the three tiny bones of our middle
ear
vital in hearing can be readily
distinguished from those of neanderthals
with careful measurement
in fact the shape differences in the ear
bones are more marked
on average than those that distinguish
our closest living relatives
chimpanzees and gorillas from each other
we had more differences with
neanderthals and chimps and gorillas
have between them
and as a chim can you tell the
difference between a chimp and a gorilla
do you think a chimp could tell the
difference between a gorilla
and his species or a gorilla again he'd
tell the difference between
a chimp and gorillas i think they would
and here's one of the gurus of
paleontology of classical
paleontology his name is chris stringer
okay
says the problem is not with
neanderthals and modern humans and all
other species that interbreed with each
other no they don't
but with a biological species concept
itself
it is only one does one of dozens of
suggested species
concepts they have the different notions
of what a species is that's what he's
saying
and one that is less useful in the
genomic age
right genome yeah talking about genes
those are the geneticists they've taken
over so now all they talk about is genes
and this guy says look
this notion of species has to be
clarified because
we have so many notions of species and
right now the one we're using is not
very useful especially in what
in this days of geneticists with its
profuse demonstrations of inner species
mix
mixing yeah that's all they talk about
admixture
interbreeding if neanderthals and homo
sapiens remain
separate long enough to evolve such
distinctive skull
shapes okay listen to that pelvises and
ear bones they can be regarded as
different species
interbreeding or not well the only
problem i got with mr stringer is that
he's saying
uh they can be regarded as different
species whether they enter bread or not
very wrong that's a wrong argument
mr stringer okay and this is the problem
the problem is they wash away the
definitions they want to continue just
talking
and what they're doing is politics at
that point and religion because
you have to define the damn word species
you have to use it consistently you
can't just keep going back and forth
and saying well i think they were the
same species
but they could not interbreed or vice
versa they were two different species
but they could interbreed
they had a mixture they passed genes to
each other
i guess you know with like a tennis ball
you pass the genes over
now you got to define the word species
if you don't have a definition for the
word species you're going to go around
in circles and that's what mr stringer
is doing here
he's uh he's kind of not he's
skirting the issue he's got to insist on
the word
species let me tell you why there's a
very popular word
among geneticists in the context of
neanderthals right and it's called
introgression intergression means that
two species different species can have a
child
a viable child and let's put the
definitions out there
got two of them there they essentially
say the same thing integration
the transfer of genetic information from
one species
to another okay introduction wikipedia
says the transfer genetic material from
one species into gene about pool of
another
this process is distinct from most forms
of gene flow
in that it occurs between what two
populations of
different species okay
so uh what do we mean by species then i
mean if integration
is sex between two different species
well let's find out what a species
what the word species means right okay
here we have it
what is a species these are definitions
you'll find
species a group of living organisms
consisting of similar individuals
capable of exchanging genes
genes or interbreeding species a group
of organisms that can reproduce
naturally with one another and create
fertile offspring and species the
largest group of organisms in which
any two individuals of the appropriate
sexes or mating types can produce
fertile offspring what is a species
two animals that can reproduce uh
successfully
in other words viable children meaning
that they're not sterile
we got that that's the definition so
what is this nonsense about
introgression
of sex viable reproductive
uh productive and uh
non um
what's the word i'm looking for well
that they they could produce offspring
that can also have uh children
okay so you you have to have you have to
have
two individuals that can have sex and
have a
child that is not um
what's the word matter that can have a
child that is also successful
okay that's the point and
we have a contradiction then between the
term introgression and the word species
because integration means two different
species can have
a child and species means that only two
from the same species can have a child
so there's a contradiction uh
between the word introgression in the
word species that's that's
my point okay we gotta we have a
contradiction
oxymoron that's what uh introgression
means and this is the word that's being
used right now
by geneticists to peddle their admixture
theory so you have to
every time a geneticist uses the word
introgression
uh you have to question that you have to
question him and say hold it what do you
mean introduction you mean two species
different species can have a child a
tiger can have a child
of viable you know a healthy child that
can also reproduce
a fertile child with a tiger
is that what you're saying and this is
where we have the problem
okay okay so uh just in case we need to
know also
what is a race okay because we use this
word race
okay race the idea that human species is
divided into distinct groups
on the basis of inherited physical and
behavioral differences
what is a race it's a political term
only humans have races there are no
races and fish
in uh uh what is it into
in gorillas any ames no
races among buffalo no one has race
except
humans because it's a political word
it's
you know the guy is black he's a
different race can you have sex with
them
can you have viable children with
someone from a different race of course
you can
you can have a white guy like me can
have a
sex viable sex with a woman in japan
with a woman in
africa or russia or south america
because we're the same species our genes
are so closely
related that there would be no problem
in having children
that's a different matter than saying
you know me having sex
with a chimp and having a child a human
see
i don't think that'll ever happen even
if i
i don't i don't care how drunk you find
me i don't think it'll ever happen
okay so um
here's my uh version of these two words
you can take this to the bank okay okay
uh how do i define these words well i'm
saying species successful
uh breeding that's what it means what do
we mean by that says
what uh won't know until they bread
because
you know it's a retroactive kind of um
definition first you have to have the
child and say oh yeah they were of the
same
species in retrospect that's the way the
word species works
because that's the way it's defined
successful breeding you know if you
don't breathe never had a child in your
life well maybe you don't know if
you're part of our species our human
species
because the word species means uh
successful breeding
and so far you haven't bred so what does
that mean that you're not part of our
species because you didn't have a child
yet
okay is a kid who is i don't know 11
years old
hasn't had a child hasn't had children
yet is he of the same species well we
don't know we got to wait till he grows
up
so if they produce their offspring
sterile that's the word i was looking
for
sterile offspring they are not the same
species
not as genetic drift okay so if they
have sex
and they cannot have a viable child
because
their genes are so different you may not
know that but
you know god mother nature father
universe the devil one of those guys
knows that your
genes are not the same that's why the
kid didn't come out or didn't come out
right
okay if they breed successfully they
were
in retrospect same species what is race
cosmetic differences within a species
typically it's a political term okay we
don't use speed
we don't use the words race usually in
terms of animals okay
they do have that uh in horse
racing yeah i guess you know you might
see some examples here and there they
talk about races of horses and so on
but in general it's a term that's used
among humans and again even with horses
and so on if they mate
they are successful that means that
they're just different
races within the same species and so the
question is whether
uh humans and neanderthals were
different species
or different races within the same
species
meaning that they could mate and have
ster successful
children if their children would have
come out
sterile we would not be able to we would
not be able to
have had any
dna that related to neanderthals
but if we have two percent well you know
that can just as well in fact
more than likely uh be related to the
fact that we had a common ancestor
sometime at
between 500 and a million years 500 000
1 million years ago that would explain
denisovans are they part of our species
no i think they were a separate animal
maybe lived out there
the last of his days somewhere in russia
and they were probably a relatively
small population
and they finally became extinct because
they had been around for
thousands of years until what their
population pyramid overturned and they
lost their genetic diversity
one thing that we can almost put our
hand in the fire when they do genetic
analysis for neanderthals and insulins
they say they had lost by that time by
the time they were gone
they had lost their genetic diversity
what a coincidence
that's exactly the theory okay
okay another turn uh subject someone
brought up
the sentinelese from sentinel island
in the middle of the indian ocean okay
sentinelese he spelled it wrong
islanders are isolated for last 60
000 years and they have not any genetic
diversity
they have lost they they may have lost
their genetic diversity because we don't
know we haven't done really a study
of the sentinelese partly because uh
these people hate anyone who comes to
their island it tries to kill them okay
and they have lost their genetic
diversity long before
because of inbri yet they continue so if
there are isolated pockets of humans
after the
economic collapse why can't they
continue why can't they reproduce okay
good question
they can restart just like in the dark
ages or maybe
in a forest tribe et cetera et cetera
okay so he's
the spell is asking you know why can't
these um
sentinelese uh reproduce
and even though they may have lost their
genetic diversity but they can still
reproduce and continue
okay what is he talking about well these
are the sentinelese so that you can see
them and they
hate again any visitors okay they're
still using a bow and arrows
that picture on the upper right is when
they killed someone and
they went uh that missionaries that went
down there got killed
and uh they weren't going to punish
these folks because you know these
guys are indians um well
indians they're what they are they're
natives of that island they've been
there for quite a while and
they don't know any better so there's no
reason they kill them or do
or punish them in any way the indian
government which owns the island
tries to protect them from outsiders but
the point is that these folks
as you can see they're the lower left
they're shooting
uh their bows their their arrows at the
helicopter
[Laughter]
they see this flying monster they don't
know what it is and so
what happens these folks uh they're very
few today
in fact they're really on their way
out in other words uh even though we
protect them
um they're more than likely gonna become
extinct
because they're having fewer children
there were like 3 000
sentinelese in the 19th century today
there's only a few hundred
two three four hundred they don't really
know how many there are they they really
think it's between 150 and 200
individuals that's it that's all that's
on the island and
that's not too many which means that you
know they're
apparently they've shrunk their
population has
shrunk drastically it's probably not
going to last long especially if
first their population pyramid
overturned assuming
right they're maybe having fewer
children than they used to have in the
past
that's one and the other one is they
probably lost their genetic diversity
from inbreeding i mean from 200
individuals
how much genetic diversity can you get
okay so yeah they're probably on their
way out if we
left them alone long enough i think they
would be wiped out all by themselves
so no i don't think they would recover
no matter how many children they have
and they cannot have too many children
because maybe uh there's not enough uh
to hunt out there okay so there's
there are constraints food constraints
okay
this is how they think they this fellow
talked about 60 000 years what is he
talking about
well apparently you see these uh
sentinelese are black
and they think they came out of africa
okay this is the closest they got to
figuring out where these folks came from
and it probably started some migration
maybe sometime around 60 000 years ago
went along the coast maybe by land maybe
by sea
with canoes or who knows what and they
went all around the
indian perimeter there and eventually
ended up in australia
and sometime maybe around sixty thousand
years ago they went into that circle
where the uh sentinelese
island are really it's got a different
name here it is
you can see it's they're called the
andaman
and the andaman islands and i've circled
there the north sentinelese island which
is where these
uh violent sentinelese live you can see
the island there uh
blow up okay and so there's like 200
individuals
living on that island they're protected
by the uh
indian government again and so the
question is you know can they survive
can
or will they become extinct and i would
say that if left
long enough they would become extinct
okay
i'm saying there are also no lost tribes
because people
mention well there could be some tribe
out there that is not connected to
our world so if the economy global
economy collapses
right money is no more we don't believe
in money anymore and god we don't trust
anymore
uh that won't affect the
hunter-gatherers
out there you know and the question is
or what i'd like to say is that there
are no lost tribes on earth we found
them all
okay so don't be surprised tomorrow they
say oh we found a new
tribe somewhere no no it's not gonna
happen we found them all
we we've got satellites for for those of
you who are not flat earthers
yeah we have satellites going around the
earth we focused on every little island
every rock that exists here on earth we
know where
everybody's at and uh here i went to
visit um a uh tribe
the tikkunas in the amazon river that
was about 30 years ago
these were my girlfriends okay
and uh these were still peaceful but
there was a tribe
uh further deeper in the uh jungles and
they
advised us not to go there because you
know we might get killed just like these
sentinelese you know they'll
attack you and so yeah
but we know they're there so so it's not
like uh
you know you're gonna be surprised uh by
new uh uh tribes and those tribes
a lot of them don't ever don't live
anymore out of just
hunter hunting and gathering a lot of
them have been
approached already especially by
missionaries
uh they trade there they've got some
report you could say some uh trading
some
contact with uh the civilized world
and so they're not completely isolated
we know where they're at
and anyways i don't think they're gonna
survive if the global economy collapses
because
people are just going to go out there
and hunt whatever they hunted
first they're going to wipe out whatever
animals out there that these people hunt
so there's going to be competition for
the animals in the jungle and i think
people
who are you know who are better armed
and who are willing to go to the jungle
they're going to be using rifles these
guys are going to go with bows and
arrows and knives
well who do you think is going to win
and after those folks
kill the animals i think they're just
going to kill the natives
so the natives it's not like the natives
are going to survive because
the rest of the world collapse it's not
going to happen like that there's going
to be no pockets there
that humans are not going to go into
humans who live
nearby in other words they're going to
go in there and they're going to try to
hunt whatever they
they can hunt so they can live another
day so we're going to be
come hunter gatherers uh people from the
towns and cities near those jungles
they're just going to go out there and
hunt whatever they can
including another human so no i don't
think it's going to happen that
tribes lost tribes are going to survive
okay another subject a person says
your thoughts on uh co2 and global
warming
oh yeah we're polluting a lot of stuff
uh
do we affect the climate well
i have to believe that eight billion
people throwing all kinds of stuff
out there in the uh in the air
we have to be affecting you know to a
certain degree we have to be affecting
the
the atmosphere of course
what's my objection to this notion of
climate change and pollution
i'm saying it's got nothing to do with
nothing
it's got nothing to do with extinction
we're not going to become extinct
because we're polluting the air we can
stop today doing anything about
climate change or pollution because it
doesn't matter
anyways we're not going to die because
of pollution we're not going to die
because of climate change
we're going to die because the global
economy is going to come
fall down to pieces when not if when
that happens when money is no more when
money you can't buy anything no one will
accept your money
in any way shape or form whether it's uh
bitcoin whether it's the fiat money
whether it's gold or even
anything you can think of your car that
you want to trade no one will accept
trade because money is no more and the
only thing of value will be
food and no one in his right mind right
in the jungle in the asteroid jungle
trades food
you don't trade food when you're at
subsistence level
you keep all the food and try to take as
much as you can from wherever
including killing murdering robbing
cannibalizing whatever is necessary to
keep you alive
so food is the most you know all animals
understand that
the only people who don't understand are
humans but all other animals out there
you know tigers lions they all
understand this they know that food
is of the most the the vital importance
okay that's the way it works and you
know humans from the cities uh
have a lot of problem trying to
understand that that's that's what's
incredible they take food so much for
granted
okay so here's uh here's pollution
venus co2 you talked about co2
venus is covered with it in fact so much
that the pressure at the
surface measured by the veneras the
russian venera probes
it's just outrageous you know like 400
times the pressure here on earth
at sea level right it's like going down
deep in the ocean several miles down
there you know the pressure just would
break you apart would squash okay that's
how much pressure is on the surface of
venus why because it's got a very thick
layer of co2 okay carbon dioxide
and uh will the earth turn into that uh
probably yes but i would have to give it
a few million years
for that to happen for earth to be like
venus
okay i don't think it'll happen before
that meanwhile
throw all the dirt you want out there
don't worry about polluting don't worry
about the
the climate it doesn't have anything at
all to do
with anything period that's it that's my
10 cents worth okay we're going to die
because of the economy not because of
climate change
so please don't worry about climate
change anymore it's
you're wasting your time climate change
just politics right now
okay so what do the plankton and
conifers have in common that causes them
to go extinct
at the same time okay plankton being
sea conifers being you know on the uh
land so referring to the fact that
dinosaurs died on land mosasaurs and
ammonites which eventually relied on
plankton they disappeared in the seas
and the moses stars in the dinosaurs
more or less went out at the same time
geologically speaking right maybe there
was a few thousand years difference but
essentially they died at the same time
we cannot determine that at the
rock level it's too nebulous
okay to to say precisely but
yeah they disappeared at the same time
the question
is for you to answer the question
uh yeah i have an answer but i'm not
going to share it with you yet i want
people to think about this
and someone gave it a try okay yeah
that's what is false says
he said it the other day but he's
insisting one more time okay
he's going to try to improve on what he
said last time he says imagine a tiny
sea creature
a is eaten by another sea creature b and
b is eaten by another sea creature c
and c by d and so on creating a food
chain okay so far so good
eventually there's a sea creature in
that change r
that is eaten by a land animal s
this this animal would not be a dinosaur
mind you it would be perhaps an
amphibian or reptile and those would be
by the dinosaurs and so on so you're
saying that all these
perhaps are part of the same food chain
uh i don't think so at least
i have a different version but no i
don't think they were all part of the
same food
chain uh the food chain in the seas is
typically
isolated from the food chain in uh
on land there are some um some animals
like you know crocs they can climb on
land and kill a deer
we have that okay we have lions that
uh sometimes uh fight with some uh
animal that's in the seas you know can't
think of them but
maybe they if they found a croc like i
think i've seen um
what is it not leopards uh
some some cat oh yeah a pack of lions uh
lionesses
and they were attacking a croc that
somehow got stranded on land i'm sure
they would have killed it and
probably eaten it you know i don't know
uh so there could be some
animals on land that eat animals in the
seas and some animals in the seas that
certainly
eat animals that are on land but i don't
think that would
i mean there's some crossover but that
crossover is that little
they don't depend on those animals uh
it's it's not because
the land animals eat sea animals and see
animals eat land animals that we have
extinction because one of them
disappears no land animals in general
chase after land animals certainly birds
chase after land animals
and sea animals usually chase after sea
animals
they have two different worlds so there
are two different
food chains there's some overlap but i
don't think it's so important to cause
the extinction
of any uh one side or the other
or both okay uh
anyways keep trying here is uh please do
wanna know extinction 101 before you do
102 meaning
please try to solve why animals
don land died approximately at the same
time as animals in the seas
okay and by that you need to start by
extinction 101 how did animals in the
past die
get a mechanism for animals in the past
share it with us no problem
okay i want to hear different ideas but
please don't use catastrophes because
those are probably not going to work
usually catastrophes either make you
know they're not
discriminatory they they cannot separate
one species from another or one group
one order
from another okay how does an asteroid
kill just the dinosaurs and leave the
uh mammals alive and so they've created
all these
other processes to account for the
different you know animals that
disappeared
and that's like ad hoc you know they
have uh like
one of the theories out there is that
the asteroid fell on a pile of sulfur
that was in the water
and that sulfur acidified
the oceans and some animals couldn't
take it and those died
just sheer luck you know that the
asteroid happened to fall on a pile of
sulfur
to kill those animals in the seas then
the other ones got killed because of
you know we had this uh what is it this
cloud covering the planet there was no
photosynthesis so
the conifers died only the conifers i
guess no uh all
all plants would have died and they say
all plants did die when there there's no
evidence of that
and that mammals were able to survive
because they ate
the tritus you know the leftovers
of dead plants and animals for three or
four years until
i guess god created plants again you
know they have all these nonsensical uh
theories okay
so let's get on with the subject matter
today in physics what is that
ray reversibility what is reversibility
well it's um says light retraces its
exact path
and talking about evidence
uh here's evidence for you look in the
mirror
and you'll see that straight ahead uh
the mirror sees you and you see the
mirror at the same time almost
almost you know you could probably draw
if you had a string you could take
eye to eye and it would be a straight
line
and if you can see the mirror but the
mirror the guy in the mirror can see you
in fact that's what happens when you see
someone in front of you
you see their eye they see your eye and
you're
kind of looking at on the same axis
how can that possibly be in quantum
mechanics where you have little
particles going back and forth
okay but i'm getting ahead of myself uh
this is where it starts it starts with
mr hiro
heron also known as hero of alexandria
okay and he lived in the first century
of the christian era he came up with a
notion which was
quite starting for his age and that is
that
you know light takes the
shortest path meaning what straight line
light travels in straight lines
something that mr newton
uh defended to the end of his days okay
he didn't like the wave thing because
waves go up and down and said
no no there's no up and down light
travels straight
and this this well said the same thing
light travels
straight it says if a ray of light
propagates from point a to point b
within the same medium the path length
followed
is the shortest possible okay so that's
uh
the uh principle that uh
hiram came up with okay
okay uh from there we can take a big
jump
maybe almost a thousand years and we
come to this fella his name is al hasan
al hazen arab guy
from iraq and he
he discovered what is known today as
snell's law he discovered
these angles especially he was studying
the eye he wanted to know how the eye
worked so he wrote his book book of
optics
did a lot of study there more for
[Music]
doctors right he studied d.i in quite a
bit of detail
that's an impressive book for you know
uh the time that he lived which was the
first millennium
the form and he wrote this the form that
reaches from the visible object to the
eye
surface passes through the transparency
of the eyes tonics
for it is among the properties of
transparency
that the forms of light and color pass
through it and continue with
rectilinearly
he's thinking about particles traveling
in a straight line
so he's talking about rectilinearly
rectilinear
travel rectilinear is a verb
it's an adverb it qualifies motion
straight is an adjective it qualifies uh
a noun in other words if you can have a
straight uh
ruler okay talk about that
that's different than talking about
rectilinear motion
that is an adverb in that because it's
qualifying a verb
and what he's saying is uh he's thinking
of particles
okay that's all we ever thought about
particles
until mr robert hook came up uh in 1665
with the notion of the wave
and it wasn't a transverse wave but he
was thinking of waves that's what he saw
through this microscope so he
wrote about it in his uh micrographia
book
1665. anyways it says if all transparent
objects were to be tested it would be
found that light will
will extend through them only in what
straight lines so he's talking about
extending
straight lines and traveling
rectilinearly
okay so make up your mind mr ahazin
does light extend in a straight line
does it travel
rectilinearly like with you know a bunch
of little
corpuscles and why would they travel
erected linearly
okay and the reason i'm asking that is
the earth is moving isn't it
well unless you're a flat earther yeah
you don't believe that but in general
most people out there think that the
earth is moving around the sun
and if that's the case we're moving
constantly and here all these
corpuscles particles
they should never travel in a straight
line okay so even if i
point my laser pointer you know the
earth is moving
so you know the beam doesn't not remain
straight if it's
made out of discrete entities you know
they should
form a even as small as you can imagine
it but it should form a curve
okay you can't get a straight line
uh when when the thing you're on is
moving
okay it moves to some degree if you're
moving to the right and you get a
bunch of balls coming out they're going
to form a little arc
okay so this is the problem and that's
not the case with light light
travels right to linearly extend
straight whichever one you want to use
but it's got to be a straight line it's
got to be rectilinear
you can't do that with discrete
particles if they're flowing
okay so this is the issue okay
visual sensation of the light and color
in a visible object is due to a
forming form coming from that visible
object to the eye he's the guy who
discovered
at least the first one who wrote about
uh something against
uh aristotle especially euclid that they
thought
the eye emitted particles
and that's why we see because light came
out of the eyes
and hazen corrected them says no no
light comes from the object to us
okay under the rope model it goes both
ways
it comes out and it goes in both ways
both directions simultaneously that's
what's good about the rope model
anyways we continue a few more years 600
more years we arrived to this gentleman
pierre the firma
and he came up with vermont's principle
essentially
he's repackaged
hiron's principle and he says the path
taken by array between
two given points in the path that can be
traversed
in the least time came out with the
least amount of time
okay and again uh he based it on what is
known today as snell's law
a dutch fellow who um
apparently came up with the equation but
this equation i think was known even
before snell
snell kind of found out about it or
maybe he recalculated maybe he
reinvented the wheel
and today he's given credit for snell's
law which is the angles
of refraction specifically okay he was
able to calculate that
angle and again the reason he can
calculate an angle is because
light either extends
straight or travels rectilinearly no
deviation whatsoever
as mr newton defended later on you know
a few years after these folks
okay so that's where we are by the
uh 17th century okay
eventually they found out that light
not only travels straight or extends
uh travels rectilinearly or extends
straight
right let's keep the language straight
here
but it retraces its path
it goes and comes along the same
path that it went and that's what's
known as the principle of ray
reversibility
amply used in optics today all opticians
know about ray reversibility great
so now how do we explain that how do how
do we simulate that with particles
when the earth is moving around the sun
we have
motion we're moving with respect to
everything in the universe
and here these series of photons
they travel straight and you might say
well i know bill
um you're so close to the mirror light
travels at 300 000 kilometers per second
it's so
fast that for all practical purposes
oh it's traveling straight right or
extending straight
really they caught you know traveling
rectilinearly that's what we should say
and it comes back along the same path
because
it moves much faster than the earth
moves
okay so let's do it a little longer
let's find out what happens when we
stretch the path
and get uh feedback and get
light coming back and it's got to do
with this
well let me just show this is just
showing the principal ray reversibility
again
light retraces its path we discovered
that okay
and so we live with that opticians they
live with this okay
but what's the issue here's uh what is
it 1971
apollo 14. before that apollo 11 later
on apollo 15 did the same thing
uh they put a uh what is known as a
retro reflector on the moon and they
shoot this laser
okay from the earth very powerful laser
that reaches
touches the retro reflector on the moon
and comes
back to earth to our computers and we
are able to see a blip
okay now the beam that goes out is
extremely powerful
the beam that comes back consists of
only a few photons a handful of photons
okay so uh we don't get what we sent out
but the important thing is
according to these people is that we're
getting a reflection from the retro
reflector on the moon
and by the time it reaches earth you
know a lot of these photons
uh get sidetracked
somewhere but two or three or 25 or
whatever
come back to the detector on earth and
we are able to map that on a computer
okay so that's what this is about and
the main reason they did this is not to
find out you know
uh how fast light travels that's
probably one issue
but they wanted to find out whether the
moon was getting closer
or moving farther away from us that's
that's the point of that's why it's
called the lunar
ranging experiment okay and this is the
retro reflector that was put on the moon
okay apollo 14.
yeah here you have the astronaut putting
the retro reflector there
and what it looks like today okay
so the from the earth they shine against
this retro reflector
and get a beam back
and essentially what arrives on earth is
just a few photons okay or that's the
explanation
because it's a very weak beam that they
receive
back okay okay um
how does quantum mechanics explain this
okay
here's the laser ranging in action okay
they pointed at the moon
and these people say that that
gazillions of
photons go but only a few okay a couple
of photons return
and uh because that's what light is
supposed to be right just a
flow of photons of discrete
particles corpuscles which are not
really
corpuscles they're just equations but
that's how they simulate it they say
well yes
it's discrete the little ball you've got
to think of them as little balls
and we shoot them at the moon and they
come back you know
gazillions go out and a few a handful
come back okay
that's how they do this or that's how
they explain it that's
that's the explanation mechanism that we
have today from quantum mechanics
uh but we have a little problem with
this because you know here we have the
earth
and the earth really goes around the sun
let me make this a little bigger here
okay
you know here's the retro reflector put
this over here
okay we have uh round trip it's uh
almost two and a half seconds okay but
see the earth moves and the moon moves
around the earth
the moon the earth moves around the sun
at 30 kilometers per second
and the moon moves around the earth one
kilometer per second
okay so we got a little bit of problem
here because we're saying hold it
we shoot these photons these loose
particles
and they have to form a curve because
you know everything is moving okay and
then out of the
they bounce off the retro reflector come
back they have to come back to the earth
where the earth is now
it's moved already you know
approximately 75 kilometers
and you know the question is is this
feasible considering
if you because we got to put something
else on top of that and that's general
relativity
general relativity says that space is
warped around
any celestial object
so not only do we have the curvature of
motion created by motion
but we have the curvature of space-time
itself
that these photons are falling into you
know they're falling into the
they're not traveling straight they're
not traveling erectile linearly they're
falling into this hole which
is created by both the moon on its side
and the earth on our side
how is it that any photons come back
okay so keep this in mind this this is
one of the
big problems that i see with their
explanation okay
let's get these out of here
okay uh how does the rope explain this
just so that you have a comparison we're
saying that well you know
all we have is just straight line to the
to the moon uh there's gazillions of
ropes
okay i'm just putting one there but
essentially you know the laser
is just a high frequency okay
short link length rope
it reaches the um what is it the
retro reflector and along that same
rope you get the signal back
okay that's it and that's where they get
a blip
on their uh on their chart on their uh
computer
okay so we're just saying that that's
what's happening
okay and uh
we we can also answer why the earth
why the moon doesn't fly away because
we're saying every atom of the moon is
tied bound to every atom on earth so we
can explain that
something that quantum cannot explain
here's quan here's the quantum version
you know why does the moon go around the
earth and not fly away if
nothing is connecting the earth to the
moon
okay how do you explain this with
particles uh you might say well we
explain where
space warp time what do you mean warp
time what kind of explanation is that
what physical interpretation
is to say that you do it with warp time
so again just because we cannot see the
interconnection between the earth and
the moon
does not mean that there's nothing there
okay
that's the issue and here's a the
same moon
orbit with the rope okay
see you can see it there you can see why
it's going around because every atom of
the moon is tied to every atom of the
sun
it's just that we cannot see or touch
these mediators which i call the
electromagnetic
ropes so this is our explanation
and uh we have an explanation at least a
physical interpretation quantum does not
that's my point okay um
we can do it with the earth orbiting and
the moon orbiting
okay here we see uh the earth is tied
and so it doesn't matter where the moon
goes if every atom from the moon is
attached to us and that white big line
there that represents
the beam that's going to the retro
reflector
so you know the moon can go anywhere it
wants we'll always find it because
we're we're connected with all these
ropes
and then there's one uh set of ropes
again it's a set
that connects the the emitter
with the receptor on the moon and along
those same ropes is where the light
comes back to us
obviously at a different frequency
okay so so we have an explanation for
both not only for the
um retro reflector the
lunar ranging experiment but also for
why the moon doesn't fly away
and on the other hand quantum mechanics
together with general relativity
have no explanation for either phenomena
okay
because you're going to have to really
go out of your way to be able to explain
why photons come back to earth
especially through warp space
and especially when both the moon and
the earth moved
constantly in motion so i'm not sure how
they're going to get any photon
photons back why would they
okay okay the a bigger problem that i
see is the following okay
and that's this one and that's that
imagine
uh the earth and the moon are moving
right so the moon is going to move
it moves one kilometer per second
light travels 300 000 kilometers per
second
okay keep those numbers light travels
fast the moon goes slow
but the moon moves it's not
instantaneous where
you can shoot photons from the earth
directly at the moon where the moon is
now
you got to shoot the photons where the
moon is going to be
one second later because it takes the
light one second really a little more
than a second to get to the moon
okay and by that time the moon ain't
there anymore the moon is 75
what is it i'm sorry one kilometer
farther down the line around the earth
but the earth also moved 30 kilometers
so the moon is not there anymore okay
and here i try to illustrate that you're
you got to point to where the moon is
gonna be
not where the moon is and so the
question is is this what they do
are they pointing at at where the moon
is not is gonna be
in one second one plus second because
it's more than
one light second away from us no they
point it directly at the retroreflector
how can they do that if the moon is
moving
unless the retroreflector atoms are
connected directly
with the uh source of the laser
that's the issue so here they have to
point at where the moon is going to be
in a little while
and yeah that's not what they do and
again they handle this
all through computers and so on so they
don't know what they're doing all they
know is that oh we're getting some
photons back and that's what
that's their explanation but if you ask
them why how is it that you're getting
photons back
and they can't give you an answer you
know they say we just do we get
we send gazillions and we get 25 back
great
what are my conclusions here okay i'm
saying that ray reversibility
light retraces its path its exact path
okay
how does quantum explain this phenomenon
discrete particles and the problem is
that the earth
as well as the moon they move constantly
move so
first not only are you sending it in an
arc
because it's not completely a straight
line you can never get
if if the earth is moving through space
you're not going to have
uh the sequence of photons traveling
exactly in a straight line
okay they have to curve then you got to
shoot them where the moon's going to be
in a little while and the moon is moving
one kilometer per second
the earth is moving 30 kilometers per
second so neither one is where it used
to be
they're both way off and so you got to
shoot the photons where the moon is
going to be
you got to shoot them in the middle of a
space that's not what they do they point
it directly at the moon
and they point it approximately in the
region where they left
because they have that map they point at
where the
retro reflector is at how is it that
they can
shoot the laser directly at the retro
reflector
if it takes if the retro reflector is no
longer there when they
when they as soon as they press the
button to shoot the laser
the you know the moon the retro
reflector the earth everything move they
have to shoot it where
it's going to be in one sec more in more
than one seconds like one and a quarter
seconds
okay so this is the problem and then the
lunar ranger experiment
arranging experiment makes it impossible
for light to consist of discrete
particles
it debunks the
quantum version of light
because quantum cannot explain it
rationally
not because i don't believe in it that's
not the debunking the debunking is
that it's an irrational explanation you
cannot
explain the lunar ranging
with particles okay they do so
because they want to but there's no they
have no way of justifying
how this is possible okay especially
when general relativity holds that space
is warped in the vicinity of all
celestial objects both the moon weighs
space and time it's weighing down's time
uh here on earth we weigh
time down uh spacetime is curved but we
get the photons anywhere
and by the way the sun is also warping
both uh the space underneath the earth
and
and the moon whichever way you can
imagine that okay
corollary ray reversibility falsifies
the discrete particle
hypothesis of quantum mechanics if we're
going to use that word falsify
by falsifying this case i don't mean
we've proven or
disproven or anything like that i'm
saying it's irrational
you simply cannot explain it by assuming
that light consists of particles
okay okay let's get to the questions and
comments that people made i had too many
i don't think i'm going to answer
all of them if i don't answer your
question please do not hit me
uh just put it up again okay i
wasn't able to get to all the questions
there were too many this time around
okay
i got uh about 10 of them so let's go
through them
okay here's the first one fella says are
the threads of the magnets also
connected to the ropes
the answer is no okay we don't connect
them to rows we connect them
only to atoms okay and again it's got to
be a twined
uh set of threads to do that
what we call a rope uh again think of
dna
you don't want to call it robe you want
to call it a chord uh
whatever string no problem does the
speed of light have anything to do with
time
with the lifespan of everything well no
the
speed of light 300 000 kilometers per
second i think it's a constant
i don't know if it's a constant only in
this part of the universe or throughout
the universe
i think it's a function of um
how much thread there is and i always
just put this example to
to put in the right context imagine
there's another universe
parallel to ours but that universe has
for example
more thread it's a bigger thread than
our thread so our thread makes all the
atoms in our universe
this other thread out there makes a
whole bunch of other atoms in the
universe we have two universes
they're not talking to each other we're
not connected in any way to that
universe because you have to be
connected through ropes from atom to
adam
and so if this is a bigger universe
maybe light has a different speed in
that
universe okay so that gives you an idea
why i'm saying that within our universe
the speed of light
is a concept probably everywhere maybe
just in our region of space
i cannot tell you that that's uh for
talk at the um water cooler or at the
bar
okay it's just speculation okay
but let me just address the first
question threads are connected to
electrons
and protons okay you've seen the
construction of my atom
uh one goes to the proton the other one
goes around and
forms the electron shell or membrane
that encapsulates the proton star
okay that's that's the model two threads
trying to form a
an electromagnetic rope and threads come
out of the e shells
and electromagnetic ropes i could say
and or right because i'm not really sure
where they come out of they could come
out of one or the other
threads come out of the e shells and
electromagnetic ropes to form the
magnetic field there you see the
magnetic field it's just a bunch of
threads that are sweeping
around they came out of the ropes or the
shells okay so they extend outwards
uh to a certain degree okay they spin
around and that whole
um panel or
you can call it a paddle of uh threads
that's what we call the magnetic field
but there's only
it's not one uh paddle it's gazillions
of paddles one on top of the other just
moving around
so the whole region is uh is swept
by these threads because you're talking
about gazillions of threads here
okay so that's the model okay
okay let's go with the next question or
comment
ah okay
says
says uh if light is independent of the
speed of the
object then doppler shouldn't apply to
light
uh this is the notion that mathematics
has that
everything has to do with speed because
that's how doppler was first
uh determined through sound you know you
have the
train coming towards you goes when it
passes you're going
so it's got to do with speed and the
fact that
it was compressing the waves when it was
coming towards you
and when it goes away it you know it uh
expands them there's more distance
between the waves that's the notion
uh that's the explanation we have for
sound
but for light we got to be careful
because that they just applied it to
light and they say okay some
planet or a star is or a galaxy is
receding
so it's got uh red shifted means it's
[Music]
if it's coming towards us blue shifted
it goes and you know you got that
the blue shifted on the spectrum and i'm
saying it's not necessarily have to do
with speed
of the celestial object coming towards
or away from us
no it's got to do with the frequency
okay something we call we
i've discussed in the past known as
tired light
and tide light is uh i think an
important point because
mathematical physics has no explanation
for tired light you can look that up
okay but essentially uh frequency
has a lot to do with it if the object is
coming towards us it could be
compressing
the links in which case you can say it's
blue shifted and when it's going away
from us it's like stretching
something out okay like stretching a
rope
in which case or the lengths of the rope
in which case you have a redshifted
but does the object have to recede or
come towards you
and the answer is no the answer is that
it can stand still
it depends on what the frequency is of
an
object of the along the main ropes that
are
that this object is emitting to us
and if it's uh got longer waves
you know then it's redshifted if it's
got short
waves then it's blue shifted so
it's not always a function of speed
it has to do also with the rope itself
what signal are we receiving from that
object
okay right now they say it's got to be
receding and
everything is receding from us in the
universe and because everything's
receding they say well that can
um is consistent with the
big bang that you know everything should
be exploding
but then we have problems because we
have the andromeda galaxy and it's blue
shift and it's coming towards us
it's 2.2 million light years away and
it's still coming towards us
how do you explain that if the balloon
of space time
is expanding everything should be
receding from each other
and the way they explain it they say
electromagnetism or gravity local
gravity
are overcoming the
recession that's the way they explain it
okay and again they need to know what
gravity is in order to say that
because driving is so far away that
the question is does that gravity is
that gravity so strong
that it reaches
this object this celestial object called
andromeda galaxy
it's pulling it towards the milky way
you know think about that we don't need
mass
to explain that but if every atom in
andromeda galaxy is
bound to every atom in the milky way
well now we have a physical mechanism uh
for pull
for action at a distance actually there
is no
action at a distance because it's just
that we can't see the mediators or touch
them
okay but you have to explain it mechanic
mechanistically
why we are pulling on the andromeda
galaxy and they're pulling on us
because there's something there in
between us you can't just say it's
gravity it's mass because
that's not a physical object hopefully
there's a physical object mediating that
transaction that phenomena
okay here's uh another question
comment if i say think about a thousand
meter wavelength does the e
shell expand that large it's an
interesting thought
yeah it is an interesting question okay
and i like these questions i like to
address them
um the the issue here is that
um and for those who may not understand
what we're talking about
he's talking about quantum jump and mr
bohr
determined in 1911 okay that
uh the atom the electron jumps
back and forth between specific levels
energy levels uh orbitals as they were
eventually called so it goes from one
orbital or energy level to another just
jumps the divide between there like if
nothing there
why does it go through in between they
don't know but they say just jumps from
here to there
okay so based on that
is where we get this we're saying that a
photon is a
link of the rope and so the
the um photon is essentially
in the case of the rope model
the the shell expands and contracts so
it doesn't go in well it goes
in between i guess but the point is in
order to do that it just swallows
one link from a bunch of ropes around it
and then when it comes back to a
smaller radius it releases that
those links okay but the issue here is
the following
it's that you have ropes from every atom
in the universe
every rope has a different frequency
different wavelength link length right
and so which one is it going to accept
is it going to accept the long one
or is it the short one that's what this
fall is asking okay which is a good
question
and all i can tell you first one is that
um
mr board determined that our only
discrete levels of energy
which we're going to say it's a link of
the rope okay
and then the other one is that maybe we
have to take an average
from all ropes in the universe maybe
it's a
weighted average where the ropes that
are
higher frequency close by have a greater
effect
that ropes that come from far away which
are maybe
long links long link
long length lengths long wavelengths if
you want okay
those are long but they they're so far
away that they have very little
influence over the object that you're
studying
and it could be that the um
stimulus that the object receives from
close by maybe a laser
shine shown on it okay
maybe that's what uh triggers uh
the main or has the main effect but
maybe it's a weighted average
so this is something that yeah needs to
be studied find out how that works all i
can tell you is that mr bohr
in other words quantum mechanics has the
same problem
because quantum mechanics says look it's
receiving energy from every atom in the
universe
because everything sends energy to this
atom
but one uh atoms throws more energy than
another atom
and so why does this atom uh
this electron fall within these two
energy levels when it's receiving
energy different energies from
gazillions of atoms
that's the question it's the same
question for quantum as it is for the
rope model
and again all we can do is we what we've
done is giving you a physical
interpretation
but that issue needs to be resolved
obviously okay
so it's a good question i don't think we
have an answer yet because
again there has to be more work done
not from the point of view of quantum
but from from the point of view of the
rope model
okay you got to figure out how it is
that you got gazillions of ropes but
still the atom only pumps
certain uh levels okay he goes
does it do it because of the atoms that
are close by they're stimulating more
than the ones farther out
is it a weighted average that's what
needs to be studied
so yeah i don't have an answer for you
but neither the quantum for that matter
uh mr um bohr simply said
it is so and we agree with him it is so
that's what we're saying i can't give
you a better answer than that it is so
okay uh one guy says uh all atoms being
interconnected explains so much but a
lot of the specifics still
elude me for example gravity and inertia
is the same no they're not the same
gravity is the opposite of inertia okay
gravity pulls inertia
tries to prevent pull okay so they're
not the same
the only difference is proximity no no
they're totally different okay
you're mixing things up there the big
scale stuff seems straightforward but
the small scale things are not yet
completely clear as
how the ropes behave in certain
situations well yeah there i
show the spoon okay the spoon is falling
but why because
every atom of the spoon is tied to every
atom of the earth
so it doesn't matter if you're talking
about a planet or the moon being
like i showed a minute ago where the
moon every atom of the moon is tied to
every atom
on earth and the earth swings the moon
around itself like you know boy swinging
a
ball around at the end of a string and
this is no different
um you know the the why does a spoon
fall to the ground
why does uh anything fall to the ground
because every atom of that object is
tied to every
atom on earth every single atom on earth
you're talking about
gazillions of atoms every rope is
converging upon that you can't see the
roast you can't touch them so don't go
to a lab you won't see it
okay you just gotta visualize this say
look
every atom is connected to every atom
okay
and then the closer it is to earth like
you see the
spoon there at different locations
ever closer to the center of the earth
the more that
the ropes fan out they're not on the
same axis the closer they are the more
they fan out
and that's what pulls the spoon to the
center of the earth to the ground
essentially but it's pulling it to the
center of the earth
which is the main point where most of
the
objects would fall in a spherical object
that's why the flat earthers have it
wrong
no the earth like all celestial objects
are round because of that okay they're
they're roundish
because gravity formed them and i'm
talking about anything
more or less big i mean you take ceres
which is one of the
asteroids the biggest asteroid it's a
small object but it's almost perfectly
round
why because it used to be a star
you can only form round objects through
the star
process that's the only way to get
roundish things out there in space okay
and uh so anything that's round out
there
put your hand in the fire it's it's
it was a star there's no other way of
creating such a round object except
through gravity
which means what all atoms being
connected to all
other atoms being pulled towards the
center and that's why you have this
accumulation of atoms
in a globular type of uh
form okay so anything that's round out
there
uh you can almost bet your life that it
was a star
i can't imagine anything else uh forming
such a round object
okay so the moon the earth
they were stars in fact uh the fact that
the earth is differentiated
in the right direction just like a star
with the heavier
atoms more or less in the center and
they get lighter as you get out
to the edge of the earth and right at
the edge of the earth where you find you
find the gases which are lighter than
the
atoms on the inside so yeah
the earth was a star no doubt about it
and the moon was a star and mercury was
a star and all the planets were stars
and except the ones that are stars like
jupiter
which is a small star that never got
enough material to ignite
okay so that's that's the theory okay
and i've got a video on that you can
look it up that the earth was
is older than the sun when the sun
ignited all this
all the planets were already here in the
neighborhood okay
the sun simply probably was the last one
to
ignite in our solar system
all these atoms eventually you know
coalesced
and at some point if there was enough
matter for the sun to
shine okay nuclear reactions
and at that point all these uh
planets like jupiter and so on they were
already rolling around that
mass okay they were already there okay
another fella says um
if the earth is spinning uh sphere
is is a spinning sphere a plum bob would
not hang plum
okay i don't know why he says that a
plum bob does hang plum
ba plum therefore the earth is not
spitting
well again uh there's there's a snapshot
of
the spoon and it's connected to every
atom on earth
the fact that i don't move uh it's
because every atom in my body is tied to
every atom on earth
if i weren't connected and the earth
spun or
moved i would be left in uh in the
middle of nowhere
fortunately every atom in my body is
tied to every atom on earth and i move
with the earth
and so does the spoon so the fact that
you know you have a plum bomb
just hanging there well every atom of
the string and the
lead ball or whatever you got at the end
of it is connected to the earth it's
stuck to the
uh to the earth an airplane flying
you know from one continent into another
every atom of that airplane is tied to
every atom of the earth that's why you
know like when i go to argentina for
example
it takes a little longer when i'm coming
back
you know because i got to catch up with
the rotation of the earth
and it's faster when i go in that
direction because the earth is moving
against the airplane more or less okay
so it takes 12 hours to go 13 hours to
come back
and and again every atom of the airplane
is stuck
is bound to every atom on earth so the
earth is
dragging that airplane with it if there
were
no uh connection between any atom of the
airplane
and the earth why would why would the
earth
uh not leave that airplane behind in the
middle of space
that's what you got to answer why does
that airplane
uh follow the earth at all like why does
the moon
follow the earth is there a problem
there i mean why doesn't the moon fly
away
what keeps it bound to the earth unless
there is
a physical connection
and if you don't put a physical
connection you are doing black magic
you're putting
spirits in that same space
which is what quantum does quantum and
general relativity
they start playing with concepts not
with objects
so they're saying in essence that
because they can't see or touch
whatever's there then uh
we're going to do it with mass we're
going to do waves we're going to do it
with particles where
zero d particles right they're going to
do it with concepts
you can't do that in physics physics you
need an object otherwise you're doing
black magic
okay another follow says also regarding
the rope model
lots of questions on that says the point
is that single twined loop cannot cross
over
itself under tension you need to have a
not
mathematical knot not sailing not or
link
of too loose for crossing atoms
the the the big problem here is that
people want to introduce too many macro
phenomena or concepts into the rope
they want to see everything under the
macro everyday experience that we have
with our objects and say well that can't
happen in mother nature's
invisible intangible world and so all i
can do is give you a word of caution and
that is
especially this word touch you need to
know what touch means you need to define
it
so the problem is this follower raises a
c
touch problem as i call them and the
problem he's got is that he
introduces too much macro simulations he
wants everything to be related to the
macro world
his world of experience and mother
nature's world doesn't work that way
as quantum and mathematical physics in
general found out
no mother nature's invisible intangible
world has to be treated
a little differently than our everyday
worlds you have to make some assumptions
about that invisible intangible world
and you cannot apply
everything macro to it among them you
can't go to the lab
and expect to see or touch it and so one
place to start
is uh the definitions okay and
because he's insinuating there that the
thread cuts across the
tension okay this is this problem he
says if you cut across there is no
tension
i think that's what he's trying to say
there it's like if you you have a
you have a string and your friend is
pulling on a string
against your hand right so it's it's
under tension but now you have someone
cut across that string
i don't know with a scissor well he's
saying that if you cut across it then
there's going to be no
tension that's the issue i think that
he's raising
and so the what i need to have him think
about
is that first we need to define the word
touch what do we mean by touch
before you can cut across you must touch
before a string can touch
another string before you can cut across
another string it's got to touch it
okay so touch proceeds cutting that's
the first one
then the second one is that i'm saying
that they blend
mother nature's uh world is is one in
which
the thread blends there's always one
thread and that thread
does not cut across and interrupt
tension at any point in time because it
blends with the
where the one is cutting across with and
they become one which is the definition
of touch
two objects become one so does molasses
touch molasses
or does the entire soup become one and
they have a
honey you know is honey touching honey
or is ton honey becoming
part of the same soup is it blending
with honey okay and that's what i'm
saying is happening
with the um with the thread
okay so this is a different notion than
we have in everyday
uh physics okay
you gotta think thinking a little bit
outside the box when you're dealing with
a rope
because mother nature obviously has
different properties
for the rope or for even if you don't
believe in the rope i don't care
or take it as an assumption uh
you got to make a different assumptions
for mother nature's world
especially if you notice that quantum
has made different assumptions
but their assumptions are quite
ridiculous because
they say a particle can be at two places
at once well i don't know if
mother nature's that [ __ ] okay she
does
run a very different world than the
visible tangible world in which we live
but i don't think she puts one part
about two places at once i think she
would be laughing at whoever
proposed such a nonsense okay so all
that stuff we've been covering lately
entanglement with this particle
affecting that one
with nothing in between black magic
particle being in two places at once
superposition
particle vibrates and not i think mother
nature would laugh at whoever proposes
all that
idiocy there's no other word for it it's
idiocy irrationality
no place in science no place in mother
nature's world i think
okay because those are different kinds
of assumptions that what we're saying
here
here we're saying look all you got to do
is uh
assume that uh the thread
is like it's like a liquid
in that sense okay it's a liquid that is
under tension and when another similar
liquid goes through it just blends
momentarily and continues
rolling so it doesn't cut the tension
okay that's my best explanation for that
how that
could be working mother nature's world
okay all you can do is
think about what i'm proposing get you
reach your own conclusions all i can do
is give you ideas the way i look at
these things okay
okay uh phil says i think structured
adam model has the
right approach because they give an
explanation by why atoms arrange
themselves in certain configuration
and why alpha and beta decay happen as
they happen
nothing random about it what is this
fellow talking about he's talking about
structured and model also known as
sam uh supposedly a new model that came
out there
but i don't know what these people if
they ever took anything in
any course in science okay
or physics because this model has been
around for a long time
uh people have already proposed what
they propose
i've read about it i haven't seen a
model a pictorial model but
in fact even from these folks okay they
don't have a model either
a physical model they have a
mathematical model and here's their
mathematical model that's all i can show
you because that's all they've got
and again these are my pictures not
theirs but they have similar pictures
in their site okay and this is
structured atom model
or sam and its proton plus an electron
equals a neutron
that's why the positive charge uh
neutralizes the
negative charge and i don't know how
you're supposed to visualize this
pictorially uh they just put a neutron
there and they just say it is so
the way i have to look at it is there
you see it on a
completely to the right there that the
plus proton
is someone stuck to the negative
electron whatever negative and positive
mean
i mean how do these particles blend what
is the mechanism that's what we want to
know they just say
it is so it is mathematically so because
positive
neutralizes negative and so their their
uh notion is the same thing as quantum
no difference
and you can see it there when they talk
about uh the forces
i call them the horses you know they
have the four forces of the apocalypse i
say it's the four horses
of the apocalypse and they have the
electrostatic horse
holds the nucleus together well what is
a force what do you mean the force
holds the nucleus together what is a
force i need to see a physical
entity holding something together you
can't say a
force or mass or gravity holds something
together
that's not an answer you need to
identify the physical
object and they don't do that because
they have no clue whatsoever
that's the issue and so yeah the
so-called sam
uh i say son of sam that's what
[Laughter]
son of a gun i think it's nonsense the
whole sam model
it's idiocy because it's quantum
that's why nothing different than
quantum they're they're just saying
oh we figured out what's in the nucleus
and what's in the nucleus
is an electron negative electron
obviously
bound or somehow stuck to paste it onto
blended with i don't know what the
answer a physical answer to that
question is
with a proton and they form a neutron
because more or less a proton plus an
electron
an electron more or less equals the mass
of a neutron we've known this for
100 years you haven't invented anything
i need to see
the picture of what you're saying please
don't talk just show a poo a movie or
a picture one of the two and you'll
never see that
because they cannot imagine what they're
saying that's the problem
okay file says location okay
is an object's location in reference to
every other object in the universe there
is no
physics without more than one object uh
i don't disagree
we see eye to eye okay we must define
the word object
before we define the word location there
is no such thing as location without an
object you need an object to have
location okay so first you need to
define what an object is
we define it as shape that would just
shape okay now we know what the word
object means
okay physics deals only with objects
that have
location meaning those that exist
not with objects that are objects but
that don't
exist exist and object are not synonyms
okay we don't deal with objects such as
superman
no snow white try barn square
those are objects as well because they
have shape what they don't have
is location they don't exist these are
objects that don't
exist get it through your thick skull
okay
and uh can we visualize imaginary
objects
i'm sorry that uh we can simulate with
imaginary objects
to visualize a mechanism in other words
you can still use imaginary objects
objects that don't exist because they're
you're just
thinking of them the table that you're
thinking of is an imaginary
object it's an object the word table
refers to an
object but it doesn't have location the
one you're thinking of
does not exist so exist and object are
not
synonyms this is where your problem is
okay you're confusing the word object
with the word exist
which mr hume and mr um
kent immanuel kent they confuse them as
well
okay and here here's what these
uh two gentlemen said it's good to keep
this in mind
here's hume and kant and i'm not gonna
read it all you just need to say
uh what mr hume said to reflect on
anything
simply and to reflect on it as existent
are nothing different from each other
that idea when conjoined with the idea
of
any object makes no addition to it to it
whatever we conceive we conceive to be
existent
wrong mr hume and then uh kant who came
a little
later said the same thing by whatever
and by however many predicates i may
think
a thing even in completely determining
it
nothing is really added to it if i add
that the thing
exists wrong mr cat
yes you have you forgot the word
location
that's the difference between exist and
object
and these two so-called philosophers
which they weren't
okay philosophy is something else never
figured
it out okay so that's important to note
okay and so um just uh summarizing there
um physics does not reify okay does not
the
does not convert these words which
mathematics
has converted into objects it doesn't do
that physics deals with
objects real objects they have to have
shape none of those words represents
that which has shape
okay and last question and false says or
comment
uh foul says weight and mass of the same
thing
yeah mass is the material or
combination of materials from the
periodic table of elements weight is a
measurement
no weight and mass are
the same thing are measurements okay we
determine mass by
weighing that's how we determine
uh mass okay how do you do it you want
to know how much
mass something has we put it on the
balance on the scale and whatever
and we weigh it what do you come up with
the weight what is the weight the mass
if you take that thing to the moon does
it weigh the same thing
no it weighs different weighs less over
there so
the weight has changed but the mass is
the same
now the mass has also changed because we
determine
the mass by weighing so we say that
the weight and mass on the earth is so
many kilograms and the weight and mass
on the moon is a different set of
kilograms lower
that's how we do it we have never never
been able to isolate the word mass from
the word weight
and mr what is it john wheeler already
is on record saying
that if you think that
mass is the quantity of matter which is
what this fellow is saying
you've got the wrong notion of mass okay
you got to go to school and learn that
mass
is not the quantity of matter especially
when you look at the circular argument
of the black hole black hole crushes all
matter out of existence
there's no matter mass allegedly is the
quantity of matter
but there is no matter and yet the black
hole
uh has no matter and it has lots of mass
so you try to figure that out okay
they've got a contradiction
which they never addressed and people
commit the
error because they think mass and weight
are different are
different things yeah they're not
they're the same thing because we've
never been able to
we never count number of atoms or
quantity of matter we never count
uh mass is something we measure
and we measure it by weighing period
we're done we're not
no mathematician has ever been able to
isolate
mass from ma from weight and then ask a
square is an object that doesn't exist
exactly perfect yes by definition
what was the definition of an object
that would just shape
and what does exist mean exist
means object meaning that we just shape
that has location if it doesn't have
location
like a square then it doesn't exist by
definition
what part did you not understand
and yeah does the square have shape uh
yes or no
i mean does a square have shape the
answer is yes
square hash shape everybody can uh i
mean
compared to mass does mass have shape no
does energy have shape no does
field have shape no people say yes it
does uh there's
see if i sprinkle iron filings i get the
field
no no that's not the way we do it and we
don't do it through experiment we want
to know
whether a field has shape don't throw
anything on it
i want to know that field that's out
there that you can't see or touch
i wonder if that has shape what is that
you got to identify the object without
throwing any
garbage in there okay so don't tell me a
field has shape it doesn't
now what a field has is a bunch of
threads are sweeping around
field is a something in motion or like
uh
mr uh james maxwell said
there's matter in motion inside a field
some exotic type of matter obviously but
matter of motion
you got to have that motion part
otherwise you don't have a field
field is not something there's no such
thing as a static
field as they call it in math no such
monster
okay field is something in motion you
got to identify the something
and then tell me how it moves why it's
moving
whatever okay or simulate the motion
and object no is not equal to exist
because an object
exists is an object plus location
object does not need location it just
needs shape
and with that i'll see you on